♪ 睫毛弯弯 ♪
♪ 眼睛眨啊眨 ♪
♪ 话说到嘴边怎么会转弯 ♪
♪ 你的微笑像月弯一弯 ♪
气氛好浪漫
需要你陪伴
2003年
我的第一场演唱会站在中正纪念堂的舞台上
我以为那是我最大的挑战
结束演唱会之后
我松了一大口气
觉得我应该可以面对接下来任何的困难
一路走来到现在
我越来越明白
当一个歌手每天都要面对不同的挑战
每天都要比昨天更努力
每一次都要有最精彩的表现
谢谢你们
让我可以继续有勇气站在这里
因为有你们一路陪我到现在
现在我要把这场演唱会送给你们
2006年的这场演唱会
我要请你们跟我一起完成这场精彩的演出
我知道我可以办得到
邀请你们为我加油好吗
哇哦
♪ Who could get a rap about a ♪
♪ Lot of mohibbright ♪
♪ My head is soul like bb from std ♪
♪ Don't you love me ♪
♪ Down on a party ♪
♪ I ♪
♪ 原来 ♪
♪ 耶嘿嘿爱你 ♪
♪ 呀啦啦啦 ♪
乌撒乌撒放轻松快乐摇摆
♪ 张开双手迎接蓝蓝大海 ♪
♪ 乌萨乌萨 ♪
♪ 把烦恼统统抛开 ♪
♪ Say yeah ♪
Osausa
♪ 眼泪放假 ♪
♪ 背上转台 ♪
♪ 爱靠过来 ♪
♪ 大声say hi ♪
♪ 没有答案就别问 ♪
♪ Why oh why ♪
想爱就跟上节拍
♪ 眼泪放假 ♪
♪ 背上转台 ♪
♪ I靠过来 ♪
♪ 大声say hi ♪
♪ 没有答案就别问 ♪
♪ Why oh why ♪
♪ 想爱就把心打开 ♪
♪ 不累不累 ♪
♪ 再往前飞 ♪
♪ 准备准备爱在心扉 ♪
呜呜撒呜撒
♪ 放轻松快乐摇摆 ♪
♪ 张开双手迎接蓝蓝大海 ♪
♪ 乌撒乌撒 ♪
♪ 把烦恼统统抛开 ♪
♪ Say yeah ♪
乌SAUSA
♪ 眼泪放假 ♪
♪ 背上站台E靠过来 ♪
大声say hi
♪ 没有答案就别问 ♪
♪ Why ♪
♪ Oh why ♪
想爱就把心打开
♪ 不累不累 ♪
♪ 再往前飞 ♪
♪ 准备准备爱在心扉 ♪
呜呜撒呜撒
♪ 放轻松快乐摇摆 ♪
♪ 张开双手迎接蓝蓝大海 ♪
♪ 乌撒乌撒 ♪
♪ 把烦恼统统抛开 ♪
♪ Say yeah ♪
乌SAWA
♪ 不累不累 ♪
♪ 再往前飞 ♪
♪ 准备准备安在心扉 ♪
乌撒乌撒放轻松快乐摇摆
♪ 张开双手迎接蓝蓝大海 ♪
乌撒乌撒把烦恼统统抛开
♪ Say yeah ♪
乌撒乌撒放轻松快乐摇摆
♪ 张开双手迎接蓝蓝大海 ♪
♪ 乌撒乌撒把烦恼统统抛开 ♪
♪ Say yeah ♪
乌撒乌撒
耶
Hello
大家好
啊因为接下来这首歌啊
我觉得还蛮符合台南的
因为就是太阳很大
所以我们今天下午彩排的时候
让我心情也非常的好
这首歌叫做太阳万岁
♪ 海阳万岁 ♪
♪ 管我们距离有多远 ♪
♪ 每天都新鲜 ♪
♪ 想你的时候 ♪
♪ 抬头看天边 ♪
♪ 太阳万岁 ♪
♪ 越过彩虹到你身边多美 ♪
♪ 梦 ♪
♪ 想想实现就会实现 ♪
♪ 我闭上眼听风说话 ♪
♪ 她说被爱的人 ♪
♪ 你已不用怕 ♪
我睁开眼睛看着微笑的额落下
你的吻是温柔的力量
我小小的
♪ 我们的爱像太阳一样喔喔哈喽 ♪
♪ 太阳万岁 ♪
♪ 距离有多远 ♪
每天都新鲜向你拍拍头拍拍头
♪ 太阳万岁 ♪
♪ 越过彩虹到你身边多美梦 ♪
想想实现开开就会实现
好棒哦
我闭上眼听风说话
♪ 她说被爱的人 ♪
♪ 你不用怕 ♪
♪ 我睁开眼睛看着微笑的阳光 ♪
♪ 你给的温暖保护爱不会照亮 ♪
♪ 永远围绕在我身旁 ♪
♪ 喔喔太阳万岁 ♪
♪ 管我们距离有多远 ♪
♪ 每天都新鲜 ♪
想你的时候
抬头看天边
♪ 太阳万岁 ♪
♪ 越过彩虹到你身边多美 ♪
♪ 梦 ♪
♪ 想想实现就会实现 ♪
♪ 可是你不要再说 ♪
你担心你能给我的不多
♪ 我很清楚 ♪
♪ 爱就像从热烈的样过来 ♪
太阳万岁
♪ 管我们距离有多远 ♪
♪ 每天都新鲜想你的时候 ♪
♪ 抬头看天边 ♪
♪ 太阳万岁 ♪
♪ 越过彩虹到你身边多美梦 ♪
♪ 想想实现就会实现好了 ♪
没有球的人哦
最后一次了
♪ 多oh新鲜 ♪
想你看着天边最后一次太阳万岁越过彩虹
♪ 当你身边做美梦 ♪
♪ 想想实现就会实现 ♪
开心吗
这首歌是用JJ林俊杰所帮我写的手表
♪ 就让我变成你的手表 ♪
♪ 贴紧手背听你的心跳 ♪
♪ 在第一时间陪你快乐夜晚 ♪
♪ 想你沉沉的睡着 ♪
♪ 拥有你每一秒 ♪
♪ 就让我的心为你读秒 ♪
♪ 滴答滴答是我的祈祷 ♪
♪ 就算是地心引力阻扰 ♪
♪ 却挡不住我向爱奔跑 ♪
♪ 为了你 ♪
♪ 我做得到 ♪
♪ 爱陪着我们寻找一种美好 ♪
♪ 有你给我暖暖拥抱 ♪
♪ 对我很重要 ♪
♪ 还不及我们寻找这一刻 ♪
♪ 刚好当时争纷争12点雨到 ♪
♪ 爱再也停不了 ♪
♪ 谢谢呵呵 ♪
♪ 就让我变成你的手表 ♪
♪ 滴答滴答是我的祈祷 ♪
♪ 就算是地心引力阻扰 ♪
♪ 却挡不住 ♪
♪ 我想爱奔跑 ♪
♪ 为了你 ♪
♪ 我做得到 ♪
♪ 爱变成我们寻找一种美好 ♪
♪ 有你给我暖暖拥抱 ♪
♪ 对我很重要 ♪
♪ 爱陪着我们寻找这一刻 ♪
♪ 刚好当时针分针12点 ♪
♪ 遇到爱再也停不了 ♪
♪ 一皱眉小心哦 ♪
♪ 有你给我暖暖拥抱 ♪
♪ 对我很重要 ♪
♪ 爱陪着我们寻找这一刻 ♪
♪ 刚好当时争纷争 ♪
♪ 12点雨到 ♪
♪ 爱再也停不了 ♪
♪ 当时针分针12点遇到爱再也停不了哇 ♪
谢谢谢谢吉祥老师
哈哈哈呜呼
♪ 我心蹦蹦跳跳 ♪
♪ 灵魂快要出窍 ♪
这感觉真好
Oh
你对着我微笑
温度越来越高
怎么办才好
♪ 眼神躲猫猫 ♪
♪ 小鹿在乱跳 ♪
♪ 跳上了心扉 ♪
♪ 心情荡秋千 ♪
♪ 脸上红苹果滋味真甜美美 ♪
♪ Baby ♪
♪ 你是谁 ♪
为什么我变成胆小鬼
好喜欢你
♪ 却说好久不见你再见 ♪
第一次面
♪ 睫毛弯弯 ♪
♪ 眼睛眨啊眨 ♪
♪ 话说到嘴边怎么会转弯 ♪
♪ 你的微笑像月弯一弯 ♪
♪ 气氛好浪漫 ♪
♪ 需要你陪伴 ♪
♪ 睫毛弯弯 ♪
眼睛眨啊眨
♪ 心动的世界变得好好玩 ♪
♪ 来玩大风吹吹什么吹 ♪
♪ 一见钟情的人 ♪
我心砰砰跳跳
♪ 灵魂快要出窍 ♪
♪ 这感觉真好 ♪
♪ oh你对着我微笑 ♪
再写眼神的猫猫
♪ 小鹿在乱跳跳上了心扉 ♪
♪ 心情荡秋千 ♪
♪ 脸上红苹果滋味真甜美 ♪
♪ 被baby你是谁 ♪
♪ 为什么我变成胆小鬼 ♪
♪ 好喜欢你 ♪
♪ 却说好久不见 ♪
♪ 一年才见 ♪
♪ 第一次面 ♪
♪ 睫毛弯弯 ♪
♪ 眼睛眨啊眨 ♪
♪ 话说到嘴边怎么会转弯 ♪
♪ 你的微笑像月弯一弯 ♪
气氛好浪漫
需要你陪伴
♪ 睫毛弯弯 ♪
眼睛眨啊眨
♪ 心动的世界变得好好玩 ♪
♪ 来玩大风吹吹什么吹一见钟情的人 ♪
♪ 睫毛弯弯眼睛眨啊眨 ♪
♪ 话说到嘴边怎么会转弯 ♪
♪ 你的微笑像月弯一弯 ♪
♪ 气氛好浪漫 ♪
♪ 需要你陪伴 ♪
♪ 睫毛弯弯眼睛眨啊眨 ♪
♪ 心动的世界变得好好玩 ♪
来玩大风吹吹什么吹一见钟情的人
♪ 睫毛弯弯眼睛眨啊眨 ♪
♪ 话说到嘴边怎么会转弯 ♪
♪ 你的微笑像月弯一弯 ♪
♪ 气氛好浪漫 ♪
♪ 需要你陪伴 ♪
♪ 睫毛弯弯眼睛眨啊眨 ♪
♪ 心动的世界变得好好玩 ♪
♪ 来玩大风吹吹什么吹一见钟情的人 ♪
♪ 谢谢 ♪
今天开心吗
好这边开心吗
前面开心吗
开心
可不可爱
♪ 留言在刚刚回完 ♪
♪ 怎么心又开始发呆 ♪
我的最新动态
♪ 是不是你也有点小期待 ♪
♪ Hi ♪
♪ 或许我该找个机会试探 ♪
♪ 看看你的心是否痛 ♪
♪ 五羊一想到你就会嘴角上扬 ♪
♪ 星期一穿拖鞋逛街 ♪
♪ 心情安慰 ♪
♪ 小事吵嘴无所谓无所谓 ♪
♪ 和你一起画面都很美 ♪
♪ 星期三笑着流眼泪 ♪
♪ 心情四天冷相依偎 ♪
♪ 想和你周末约会 ♪
♪ 哇哦流言才刚刚挥完 ♪
怎么心又开始发呆
♪ 一样没一个 ♪
♪ 我的最新动态是不是也有点小期待 ♪
♪ Hi ♪
♪ 或许我该找个机会试探 ♪
♪ 看看你的心是否同样一想到你就会唔上扬 ♪
等下会有一个特别的人哦
♪ 星期一穿拖鞋逛街 ♪
♪ 心情很微 ♪
♪ 小事吵嘴无所谓无所谓 ♪
♪ 和你一起画面都很美 ♪
♪ 星期三笑着流眼泪 ♪
♪ 心情四天冷相依偎 ♪
♪ 想和你周末约会 ♪
哦耶会有一个人来参与我们的演出
嘿嘿嘿
现场的观众请你跟我登上卫冕的宝座
♪ 星期一穿拖鞋逛街 ♪
♪ 心情很微 ♪
♪ 小事吵嘴无所谓无所谓 ♪
♪ 和你一起画面都很美 ♪
♪ 星期三笑着流眼泪 ♪
♪ 星期四天冷相依偎 ♪
♪ 想和你周末约会 ♪
♪ 耶喔唔喔欧耶 ♪
♪ 都很美 ♪
♪ 喔喔喔啊哈 ♪
♪ 想和你周末约会耶 ♪
♪ 嘿嘿嘿 ♪
♪ 右摇左摇右摇左摇 ♪
耶
想和你来
谢谢这个送给你
谢谢掌声鼓励耶
接下来要唱的这首歌哈
其实嗯是很特别的一首歌曲
这首歌我也很喜欢
叫做丢铜板
你送给我99朵玫瑰
也送给我
我爱掉的眼泪
你能带我起飞
♪ 也能让期待跌倒受伤 ♪
♪ 爱上你 ♪
就像吃巧克力
♪ 苦苦的吃露 ♪
浓浓密密口吃下
♪ 全部 ♪
♪ 让我两种味道都满足 ♪
♪ 像云霄飞船高低起伏 ♪
♪ 既害怕却又享受投入 ♪
♪ 爱就是让人快乐 ♪
♪ 又有一点点想哭 ♪
♪ 像隔了汽水 ♪
♪ 开瓶以后 ♪
♪ 气泡慢慢的不再跳动 ♪
♪ 我还是喜欢在你笑容里迷人的甜度 ♪
♪ 正面是你对我的好 ♪
♪ 反面是你发过的脾气 ♪
爱情就像丢铜板
♪ 苦与乐 ♪
♪ 一半一半失眠是你要的自由 ♪
♪ 反面是我要的浪漫 ♪
♪ 我们的爱不管谁分胜负 ♪
♪ 都一半痛苦 ♪
♪ 一半幸福 ♪
你送给我99朵玫瑰
也送给我为爱掉的眼泪
♪ 你能带我起飞 ♪
♪ 也能让期待跌倒受伤 ♪
♪ 爱上你 ♪
♪ 就像吃巧克力 ♪
♪ 苦苦的吃软浓浓蜜蜜 ♪
一口吃下
♪ 全部让我两种味道都满足 ♪
♪ 像与小飞车高低起伏 ♪
♪ 既害怕却又享受投入 ♪
♪ 爱就是让人快乐 ♪
♪ 又有一点点想哭 ♪
♪ 像可乐汽水开瓶以后 ♪
♪ 气泡慢慢地不再跳动 ♪
♪ 我还是喜欢在你笑容里迷人的甜度 ♪
♪ 正面是你对我的好 ♪
♪ 反面是你发过的脾气 ♪
♪ 爱情就像个铜板 ♪
♪ 苦与乐 ♪
♪ 一半一半正面是你要的自由 ♪
♪ 反面是我要的浪漫 ♪
♪ 我们的爱不管谁分胜负 ♪
♪ 都一半痛苦 ♪
♪ 一半幸福 ♪
♪ 依旧浮生 ♪
♪ 你的雨落花 ♪
♪ 正面是你对我的好 ♪
♪ 反面是你发过的脾气 ♪
爱情就像丢铜板
♪ 苦与乐 ♪
一半一半转变是你要的自由
♪ 反面是我要的浪漫 ♪
♪ 我们的爱不管谁分胜负 ♪
♪ 都一半痛苦 ♪
♪ 一半幸福 ♪
♪ 呜耶 ♪
♪ It's fb ♪
♪ 你要的自由 ♪
♪ 我要的浪漫 ♪
♪ 一半幸福 ♪
♪ Da da da di ♪
Da da da da da
Oh yeah
谢谢谢谢王心凌耶
等一下哦
这是我们刚刚拍的
要送给谁
拜拜再一次热情掌声
谢谢王心凌
Honey
♪ 你把爱放进我的心里 ♪
♪ 关上耳朵 ♪
♪ 我用心在听 ♪
♪ 你用爱为我打造贴身耳机 ♪
♪ honey保持神秘 ♪
♪ 你还是猜中我的心 ♪
♪ 播放我的心情 ♪
♪ 满满六颗心 ♪
♪ 往心里微笑哭泣 ♪
♪ 放心会有你 ♪
♪ 贴着心 ♪
♪ 贴得好近 ♪
♪ 每分钟零距离点一首歌给honey ♪
♪ 甜言蜜语隔空传递 ♪
♪ 交响着我表情 ♪
♪ 更新彼此最新的秘密 ♪
♪ 爱要随身听 ♪
♪ 随时感应 ♪
♪ 多喜欢你叫喊你 ♪
♪ 甜言蜜语 ♪
♪ 在我心里爱你的空 ♪
♪ 写日记 ♪
♪ 甜蜜点心 ♪
♪ 充满惊奇 ♪
♪ 都不会 ♪
♪ 你让我忘心里 ♪
♪ 用心品味你 ♪
那边的朋友
♪ 会不会唱啊 ♪
Honey
你把爱放进我的心里
♪ 关上耳朵 ♪
♪ 我用心在听 ♪
♪ 你用爱为我打造贴身耳机 ♪
♪ Honey ♪
♪ 保持神秘 ♪
♪ 你还是猜中我的心 ♪
♪ 播放我的心情 ♪
♪ 满满六颗星 ♪
♪ 我的心里微笑哭泣 ♪
♪ 放心会有你贴着心 ♪
♪ 贴得好近 ♪
♪ 每分钟零距离准备好没有 ♪
♪ 第一首歌给honey say b隔空传递 ♪
♪ 加上超多表情 ♪
♪ 更新彼此最新的秘密 ♪
♪ 爱要随身听 ♪
♪ 随时感应 ♪
♪ 多喜欢你叫喊你甜言蜜语 ♪
♪ 在我心里爱你的狂学日记 ♪
♪ 甜蜜的心充满惊奇 ♪
♪ 都不会腻 ♪
♪ 让我往心里用心品味你 ♪
耶嘿嘿谢谢谢谢你们
嘿天哪
平常你们今天大家都有带相机
对不对
有平常都是你们拍我啊
今天我可要反拍大家了
我看看我的手可以拿多远
我希望我的相机里面统统都是人好不好
可不可以举起你们的手啊
我蹲下来咯
一哦不对
我应该高一点哦
1231啊
没有开闪光灯啊
再一次哦
好123
耶谢谢好
现在麻烦你们拿起你们的相机啊
因为啊我从来没有看过
就是很多很多台相机一起闪
这么多台一起闪好不好
然后就想现在先不要拍
现在先不要拍好了
我知道三哦
请麻烦灯光帮我方案
我数到三哈
哦好棒哦
有没有
我在台上看
我觉得很开心诶
就是到处都是光
当然我们现在又要谢谢你们帮我完成啦
接下来呢要唱的这首歌跟光也很有关系
下次好梦的光点
♪ 奔跑在人群里面 ♪
♪ 我看不见 ♪
♪ 偶尔和孤单遇见 ♪
♪ 在原地转圈圈 ♪
♪ 我跟自己面对面 ♪
♪ 踮起了脚尖 ♪
♪ 靠近了一点 ♪
♪ 梦就住在前面 ♪
♪ 我不管淋湿的脸 ♪
♪ 用坚定的双眼换一个脚步 ♪
♪ 欣赏磅礴大雨的阴天 ♪
♪ 未来还有另一面 ♪
♪ 能不能看见 ♪
靠近了一点
♪ 我不再蒙着眼 ♪
幸福的起点
♪ 幸福的起点有彩虹 ♪
♪ 花朵铺满在一整片蓝天 ♪
♪ 不管有多么远 ♪
♪ 有你在我身边 ♪
♪ 我追着梦的光点 ♪
♪ 是因为有了勇气才不怕危险 ♪
♪ 你的爱没有上限 ♪
♪ 给我力量 ♪
♪ 继续往前 ♪
♪ 我追着梦的光点 ♪
♪ 心连心站在同一边的起跑线 ♪
♪ 加速度冲出线 ♪
♪ 仰起了脸 ♪
♪ 我们微笑 ♪
♪ 一起迎接幸福终点 ♪
♪ 我不管淋湿的脸 ♪
♪ 用坚定的双眼换一个脚步 ♪
♪ 欣赏磅礴大雨的阴天 ♪
♪ 未来还有另一面 ♪
♪ 能不能看见 ♪
♪ 靠近了一点 ♪
♪ 我不再蒙着眼 ♪
♪ 明天的笑脸 ♪
♪ 幸福的起点有彩虹 ♪
♪ 花朵铺满在一整片蓝天 ♪
♪ 不管有多么远 ♪
♪ 有你在我身边 ♪
♪ 我追着梦的光点 ♪
♪ 是因为有了勇气才不怕危险 ♪
♪ 你的爱没有上限 ♪
♪ 给我力量 ♪
♪ 继续往前 ♪
♪ 我追着梦的光点心练习站在同一边的起跑线 ♪
♪ 加速度冲出线 ♪
♪ 仰起了脸 ♪
♪ 我们微笑 ♪
♪ 一起迎接幸福终点 ♪
♪ 我追着梦的光点 ♪
♪ 是因为有了勇气才不怕危险 ♪
♪ 你的爱没有上限 ♪
♪ 给我力量 ♪
♪ 继续往前 ♪
♪ 我追着梦的光点 ♪
新练习
♪ 站在同一边的起跑线 ♪
♪ 加速度冲出线 ♪
♪ 仰起了脸 ♪
♪ 我们微笑 ♪
♪ 一起迎接幸福终点 ♪
啊谢谢谢谢吴哲
呵呵精不精彩精彩
接下来唱的歌曲啊
我想大家都一定会唱这样
然后一般来讲呢他是我跟大家大合唱的歌曲啊
叫做当你
♪ 如果有一天我回到从前呜回到最原始的我 ♪
你是否会觉得我不错
♪ 如果有一天我离你遥远 ♪
♪ 不能再和你相约 ♪
♪ 你是否会发觉我已经说再见 ♪
会唱吗
一起唱好不好
♪ 当你的眼睛眯着笑 ♪
♪ 当你喝可乐 ♪
♪ 当你吵 ♪
♪ 我想对你好 ♪
♪ 你从来不知道想你想你也能成为嗜好 ♪
♪ 当你说今天的烦恼 ♪
♪ 当你说夜深你睡不着 ♪
♪ 我想对你说 ♪
♪ 却害怕都说错 ♪
♪ 好喜欢你 ♪
♪ 知不知道 ♪
♪ 如果有一天梦想都实现 ♪
后面的成了永远
你是否还会记得今天嘿加入我们好吗
我们都发觉那自变了呢
♪ 原来什么都可以 ♪
♪ 我们是否还会停留在这里 ♪
♪ 大家一起来好吗 ♪
♪ 当你的眼睛眯着笑 ♪
♪ 当你喝可乐 ♪
♪ 当你吵 ♪
♪ 我想对你好 ♪
♪ 你从来不知道想你想你也能成为嗜好 ♪
♪ 当你说今天的烦恼 ♪
♪ 当你说夜深你睡不着 ♪
♪ 我想对你说 ♪
♪ 却害怕都说错 ♪
♪ 好喜欢你们知不知道 ♪
♪ 也许口气让我想得太多 ♪
♪ 也许该回到被窝 ♪
♪ 梦里会相遇 ♪
♪ 就毫不犹豫大声的说一起唱 ♪
♪ 当你的眼睛眯着笑 ♪
♪ 我想对你好 ♪
♪ 你从来不知道想你 ♪
♪ 想你也能成为嗜好 ♪
♪ 我想对你说 ♪
♪ 却害怕都说错 ♪
♪ 好喜欢你 ♪
♪ 知不知道 ♪
啊哼哼哼
好棒哦
你们真的太爱你们了
因为太爱你们啦
今天其实嗯嗯主要是要唱新歌嘛
对不对
可是因为太爱你们啦
你们有没有觉得有什么歌还是想听的
对不对
子红呵好吧
既然大家都想听爱你的话呢
我就要请我的dancer上台啦
然后要介绍这首歌给大家听
要一起唱哦
好爱你
Yo yo yo yo cindy
♪ What what's wrong with me me ♪
♪ Yo yo ♪
♪ Cindy baby ♪
♪ what's wrong with me呵 ♪
Cindy
♪ Give me your love ♪
♪ You make me sk all the time ♪
♪ Now now ♪
♪ 怎么我一直狂打喷嚏 ♪
♪ 在凌晨3.26分 ♪
♪ Let me sing ♪
♪ a song陪你入睡 ♪
♪ Ha yo ♪
♪ What is love say ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Oh say ♪
Yo yo
♪ Yes ♪
♪ And no say ♪
So do i really do love you
♪ so如果你突然打了个喷嚏 ♪
那一定就是我在想你
♪ 如果半夜被手机吵醒啊 ♪
♪ 那是因为我关心 ♪
♪ 常常想你 ♪
♪ 说的话是不是别有用心 ♪
♪ 明明很想相信 ♪
♪ 却又忍不住怀疑 ♪
♪ 在你的心里 ♪
♪ 我是否就是唯一爱 ♪
♪ 就是有我常烦着你 ♪
♪ Oh baby ♪
♪ 情话多说一点 ♪
♪ 想我就多看一眼 ♪
♪ 表现多一点点 ♪
♪ 让我能真的看见 ♪
♪ Oh bye ♪
♪ 少说一点 ♪
♪ 想陪你不只一天 ♪
♪ 多一点 ♪
♪ 让我心甘情愿爱你 ♪
Call me up
What your hands up
♪ Put your hands up ♪
喜欢在你的臂弯里胡闹
♪ 你的世界是一座城堡 ♪
在大头贴画满心号
别在手机上对你微笑
♪ 常常想我说的话 ♪
你是否听得进去
♪ 明明很想生气 ♪
却又止不住笑意
♪ Oh oh ♪
在我的心里
♪ 你真的就是唯一爱 ♪
♪ 就是有我常烦着你 ♪
♪ Oh baby ♪
♪ 情话多说一点 ♪
♪ 想我就多看一眼 ♪
♪ 表现多一点点 ♪
♪ 让我能真的看见 ♪
♪ Oh bye ♪
♪ 少说一点 ♪
♪ 想陪你 ♪
♪ 不只一天 ♪
♪ 多一点 ♪
♪ 让我心甘情愿爱你 ♪
接下来要欢迎我的好朋友徐伟伦
♪ 耶耶耶 ♪
我们一起跳舞哦
Oh ho o baby
♪ 情话多说一点 ♪
♪ 想我就多看一眼 ♪
♪ 表现多一点点 ♪
♪ 让我能真的看见 ♪
♪ Oh bye ♪
♪ 少说一点 ♪
♪ 想陪你不只一天多一点 ♪
♪ 让我心甘情愿爱你 ♪
♪ Oh baby ♪
♪ 情话多说 ♪
♪ 现想我就多看到中场表现多一点点 ♪
♪ 让我能真的看见 ♪
♪ Oh b ♪
♪ 少说一点 ♪
♪ 想陪你不只一天多一点 ♪
♪ 让我心甘情愿爱你 ♪
♪ 多一点才会慢慢发现哈 ♪
♪ 因为你让我心甘情愿 ♪
王心凌2003~2005辉煌成绩大事纪来
灰姑娘2003年推出首张专辑
以主打歌灰姑娘的眼泪出道
王心凌在短短两年之中
从外人眼中的灰姑娘蜕变为今日的销售天后
时间虽短
心灵在唱片戏剧代言的成绩却闪亮耀眼
两年四张台湾地区突破50万张
销售总数
奠定台湾销售天后地位
♪ 灰姑娘的眼泪就像流星坠落海底 ♪
♪ 痛到心里 ♪
♪ Oh baby ♪
♪ 情话多说一点 ♪
♪ 想我就多看一眼 ♪
♪ 多喜欢你叫honey ♪
♪ 甜言蜜语 ♪
♪ 在我心里爱你的暴雪日记 ♪
♪ 哒哒哒换上快乐舞步 ♪
哒哒哒两场表演活动汇聚将近4万人
证明人气天后
♪ 对你说今天的烦恼 ♪
♪ 当你说夜深你睡不着 ♪
♪ 我想对你说 ♪
♪ 却害怕 ♪
♪ 都说错 ♪
♪ 好喜欢你 ♪
♪ 知不知道啊 ♪
♪ 城门城门几丈高 ♪
♪ 带着爱情已代码进城堡 ♪
♪ 再一步步将你围绕 ♪
♪ 抓住你 ♪
♪ 你别跑 ♪
♪ 给我拥抱 ♪
两部偶像剧档档收视第一
所有戏剧单位争相邀请戏剧小天后
♪ 我不是不知道没有你的日子会有多么煎熬 ♪
♪ 就算是我傻得可笑 ♪
♪ 失去当真得到 ♪
♪ 只要能够对你好 ♪
♪ 爱是花儿的芬芳 ♪
♪ 是蝴蝶的翅膀 ♪
♪ 是伤心的不公 ♪
♪ 你是他的方向 ♪
12大广告代言攀上广告小天后
♪ 嘟嘟哒哒哒嘟嘟嘟噜噜哒哒哒 ♪
♪ 哒哒哒换上快乐舞步 ♪
♪ 哒哒哒 ♪
2006年音乐戏剧广告代言持续增加
王心凌在华语市场继续闪耀
这张专辑里面的歌曲叫做you are my only love
在这里要谢谢很多人呐
谢谢东风卫视啊
所有的工作人员
谢谢台南市政府
谢谢我的家人
谢谢可爱的你们
♪ 紧握着你的手 ♪
♪ 天很冷 ♪
♪ 路口正亮着红灯 ♪
说不出一句话
♪ 傻傻的站着 ♪
♪ 你和我 ♪
♪ 熟悉的这首歌着空气一起分享的呼吸 ♪
♪ 说完再见以后 ♪
♪ 说过的爱过的要怎么继续 ♪
♪ 呜好想再多一分钟 ♪
♪ 感觉你的温度 ♪
♪ 你的味道 ♪
♪ 你温柔的手在转身之后发现我的眼睛看着天空 ♪
♪ 突然下起了大雨 ♪
♪ 从最初到最后要走到时间的尽头 ♪
♪ 不变的守候 ♪
♪ You are my only love ♪
♪ 要记住我们曾拥有海阔天空 ♪
♪ 放开手才知道冷风吹心好痛 ♪
新歌如果会唱呢
♪ 还是一起唱好吗 ♪
♪ 紧握着你的手 ♪
♪ 天黑了 ♪
♪ 路口正亮着红灯 ♪
♪ 说不出一句话 ♪
傻傻的站着
♪ 你和我 ♪
♪ 熟悉的这首歌着空气一起分享的呼吸 ♪
♪ 说完再见以后 ♪
♪ 说过的爱过的要怎么继续 ♪
♪ 好想再多一分钟 ♪
♪ 感觉你的温度 ♪
♪ 你的味道 ♪
♪ 你温柔的手在转身之后 ♪
♪ 发现我的眼睛跟着天空突然下起了大雨 ♪
♪ 从最初到最后要走到时间的尽头 ♪
♪ 不变的守候 ♪
♪ You are my only love ♪
♪ 要记住我们曾拥有海阔天空 ♪
♪ 放开手才知道冷风吹醒 ♪
♪ 好好痛 ♪
♪ 从最初到最后 ♪
♪ 要走到时间的尽头 ♪
♪ 不变的守候 ♪
♪ you are my又only love ♪
♪ 要记住我们曾拥有海阔天空 ♪
♪ 放开手才知道冷风吹心好痛 ♪
♪ You are my only love ♪
♪ Only love ♪
哇刚才还感谢很多人
对不对
还有好多人没有感谢完哦
啊还有兰博舞蹈教室啊
真的很多同事的帮忙
这首歌是什么
知道哦
蒲公英在游荡
♪ 像野花闪着微亮的光芒 ♪
趁着夜晚找寻幸福方向
♪ 难免会受伤 ♪
♪ 弯弯小路上 ♪
♪ 蒲公英在歌唱 ♪
♪ 星星照亮在起风的地方 ♪
♪ 月亮诶乘着微风飘向未知远方 ♪
♪ 幸福路也许漫长 ♪
♪ 难过的时候谁在身边陪我掉眼泪 ♪
♪ 失败无所谓 ♪
♪ 你在左右 ♪
♪ 月光多美 ♪
♪ 弯弯月光下 ♪
♪ 我轻轻在歌唱 ♪
♪ 从今以后不会再悲伤 ♪
♪ 闭上双眼 ♪
♪ 感觉你在身旁 ♪
♪ 你是温暖月光 ♪
♪ 你是幸福月光 ♪
♪ 耶可以让我看到你们吗 ♪
♪ Hello ♪
♪ 后面的有吗 ♪
♪ 弯弯月光下 ♪
♪ 蒲公英在游荡 ♪
♪ 小夜华 ♪
♪ 闪着微亮的光芒 ♪
♪ 趁着夜晚找寻幸福方向 ♪
♪ 难免会受伤 ♪
♪ 弯弯小路上 ♪
♪ 蒲公英在歌唱 ♪
♪ 星星照亮在起风的地方 ♪
♪ 乘着微风飘向未知远方 ♪
♪ 幸福也许漫长 ♪
♪ 你难过的时候 ♪
♪ 谁在身边陪我掉眼泪 ♪
♪ 失败无所谓 ♪
♪ 你在左右 ♪
♪ 月光多美 ♪
♪ 弯弯月光下 ♪
♪ 我轻轻在歌唱 ♪
♪ 从今以后不会再悲伤 ♪
♪ 闭上双眼 ♪
♪ 感觉你在身旁 ♪
♪ 你是温暖月光 ♪
♪ 你是幸福 ♪
哟呐呐呐哦啦啦啦啦啦啦
我在月亮上歌唱
♪ 闭上双眼 ♪
♪ 感觉你在身旁 ♪
♪ 弯弯月光下 ♪
我轻轻在歌唱
♪ 从今以后不会再悲伤 ♪
♪ 闭上双眼 ♪
♪ 感觉你在身旁 ♪
♪ 你是温暖月光 ♪
♪ 你是幸福 ♪
♪ 月光 ♪
爱谢谢我也爱你们
后面的拜拜
再一次掌声
谢谢谢谢王心凌掌声鼓励
现场所有的好朋友还想不想听
还要不要听
要听谁唱
平听谁唱
王心凌听谁唱
王心凌
大家一起来啊
这时候要喊什么
大家应该都知道好不好
一起来准备123
Go apple
Apple
Apple apple
大三安
再大声再大声
拍手拍手拍手拍手拍手拍手拍手拍手拍手
拍手拍手
给自己掌声鼓励一下嗯
演唱会到最后
我有一些话想要跟大家说
可是我怕我无法在舞台上
很平静地把这段话说完
所以我就先录了这段VCR
要说出我心里的话
还有我要感谢的对象
我的经纪公司大声音乐的所有同事们
经纪人DAVID老师
小慧姐
思雨哥
还有每天陪伴我的小珍
艾回唱片的老板宫崎先生
DAVID哥
马克do文元哥
小宝姐
佳蓉姐
王妈大香姐坤达
还有所有辛苦的同事们
还有所有照顾我的媒体朋友
谢谢你们一路上帮助我
嗯不时的给我支持
不时的帮我打气
也不时的提醒我要更努力
最后当然还要谢谢所有支持我的歌迷朋友们
谢谢你们一路上的陪伴
给我信心
给我力量
在办这场演唱会之前
有一些风风雨雨
我才知道自己并不如想象的这么坚强
很多时候我也是会感到挫折
感到害怕
我知道我还要更勇敢
也因为有了大家的力量
我才能站在这个舞台
不怕难关的继续演出
我以后一定会更努力的
想到你们
我就觉得我不孤单
你不管未来还有多少的挑战
不要说你爱我
我知道我会更勇敢的
再一次要跟大家说声谢谢
谢谢大家
是你们让我有勇气有力量完成这场演唱会
这首歌是什么
知道哦
♪ 我还想像你拒绝一次是好奇心 ♪
♪ You this out the rain ♪
♪ 在我心里变成了秘密 ♪
♪ 我想见见你们 ♪
♪ 不要说你爱我 ♪
♪ 如果你的心里没有这么做 ♪
♪ 只是勉强的敷衍我 ♪
♪ 默默走不回头 ♪
♪ 我会清楚明白你要的是什么 ♪
♪ 无需勉强的安慰我 ♪
♪ 到现在还是深深的深深的爱着你 ♪
♪ 是爱情的 ♪
♪ 友情的都可以 ♪
♪ 那时候吼嘿吼 ♪
♪ 我真的很感动 ♪
♪ 从来没想过会在台上哭 ♪
谢谢你们
♪ 一定爱我 ♪
♪ 你想我 ♪
♪ 如果你的心里没有这么做 ♪
♪ 只是勉强的敷衍我 ♪
♪ 我知道了会很难受 ♪
♪ 我要你默默走不回头 ♪
♪ 我会清楚明白你要的是什么 ♪
♪ 无需勉强的安慰 ♪
♪ 我说奇怪的理由 ♪
♪ 到现在还是深深地深深地爱着你 ♪
♪ 是爱情的友情的都可以 ♪
♪ 那是我心中的幸福 ♪
♪ 我知道它苦苦的深深地深深地爱着你 ♪
♪ 是爱情的友情的都可以 ♪
♪ 那是我心中的幸福 ♪
♪ 我知道它苦苦的 ♪
哎呦他在下面想说不可以哭
哎这边帮我接唱了好不好
♪ 我会好好的 ♪
♪ 我会好 ♪
♪ 花海香香地花海 ♪
♪ 想象的世界一直去回忆 ♪
♪ 真美丽 ♪
还有哦
♪ 我是想着你 ♪
♪ 我是想着一直想着你 ♪
♪ 一直想着你 ♪
♪ 你在我心底变成了秘密 ♪
♪ 到现在还是深深的深深的爱着你 ♪
♪ 是爱情的友情的都可以 ♪
♪ 那是我心中的幸福 ♪
♪ 我知道它苦苦的到现在还是深深地深深地爱着 ♪
♪ 是爱情的友情的都可以 ♪
♪ 那是我心中的幸福 ♪
♪ 我知道它苦苦地要给你远方的祝福 ♪
♪ 我知道它苦苦地 ♪
♪ 杨永远最美 ♪
♪ 你 ♪
谢谢呵呵
哎呦呵呵
没想到会在台上哭
我真的太感动
然后也完成了一个好一个阶段了
这样谢谢哎呦
你们不要再再说我哭了哈哈
而且在这里呀还要谢谢很多人
还有就是我的家人呐
要再次谢谢他们
他们真的很多人大家都来了
然后还有就是特别从北部来的
从南部来的
当然还有在台南的你们
谢谢你们也都赶来看嗯
还要谢谢台南市政府
还要谢谢东风
谢谢东风幕后的所有工作人员
猴子哥啊
小芳哥啊
然后还有嗯我经纪公司呃的很多同事
刚才都已经谢谢过了
还谢谢三立
完全娱乐
还要谢谢朱老师
谢谢蓝波舞蹈教室
他们真的很情意的在帮忙我做这场演唱会
谢谢蓝波老师
谢谢所有的dancer
现在呢真的要唱最后一首歌曲了
最后一首歌我希望你们都可以
真的很开心的跟我一起唱
好不好
因为这首歌大家应该还算熟悉
叫做
♪ 让开心先过转弯 ♪
♪ 想想搜寻好结果 ♪
♪ oh向前向后转身 ♪
♪ 再向左脱掉烦恼 ♪
♪ 谁的分最多 ♪
♪ 哒哒哒嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟哒哒哒 ♪
♪ 哒哒哒换上快乐舞步 ♪
♪ 哒哒哒 ♪
♪ 嘿嘿嘿嘿 ♪
♪ 有话要直说 ♪
♪ 别让机会又擦肩溜走 ♪
♪ 遇见和你勇敢say哈哈 ♪
♪ 苍蝇电流在穿梭 ♪
♪ 哦哒哒哒嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟哒哒哒哒哒哒 ♪
♪ 换上快乐舞步 ♪
♪ 哒哒哒 ♪
♪ 为自己加油 ♪
♪ 小心放假 ♪
♪ 幸福等等我哦 ♪
♪ 恋爱节奏要天长地久 ♪
♪ One two three four ♪
♪ 脚步别落后 ♪
♪ oh da da d嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟哒哒哒哒哒哒 ♪
♪ 换上快乐舞步 ♪
♪ 哒哒哒 ♪
Hey hey
♪ Hey hey ♪
♪ 和我来交手 ♪
♪ 抛开忧愁 ♪
♪ 世界照料过 ♪
♪ Oh a b c d ♪
♪ 答案是什么 ♪
♪ 跟着感觉不用想太多哦 ♪
♪ 哒哒哒嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟哒哒哒哒哒哒 ♪
♪ 换上快乐舞步 ♪
♪ 哒哒哒哈哈 ♪
嗨起来嗨起来好不好啊
♪ 让开心先过转弯小巷 ♪
♪ 搜寻好结果 ♪
♪ oh向前向后转身 ♪
♪ 再向左躲掉烦恼 ♪
♪ 谁得分最多 ♪
♪ 哒哒哒嘟嘟嘟噜嘟哒哒哒哒哒哒 ♪
♪ 换上快乐舞步 ♪
♪ 哒哒哒 ♪
♪ 嘿嘿嘿嘿 ♪
♪ 等会来教授怎么唱啊 ♪
♪ 跳开忧愁 ♪
♪ 世界超辽阔哦 ♪
♪ ABCD答案是什么 ♪
♪ 跟着感觉不用想太多哦 ♪
♪ 哒哒哒嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟哒哒哒哒哒哒 ♪
♪ 换上快乐舞步 ♪
♪ 哒哒哒 ♪
♪ 哒哒哒嘟嘟嘟哒哒哒 ♪
哒
♪ 换上快乐舞步 ♪
♪ 哒哒哒哒哒哒嘟嘟嘟噜嘟哒哒哒哒哒哒 ♪
♪ 哒哒咩哒哒哒 ♪
♪ 嘟噜嘟噜噜哒哒哒哒哒哒 ♪
♪ 换上快乐舞步 ♪
♪ 哒哒哒 ♪
谢谢谢谢谢谢谢谢你们
右边的
♪ say耶 ♪
蓝波老师跟我们一起
谢谢你
谢谢蓝波老师
谢谢谢谢谢谢
谢谢你们
♪ 谢谢拜拜 ♪
♪ 左边的朋友 ♪
你我们要过去咯
要跟你们说谢谢
耶谢谢你们
♪ 谢谢谢谢 ♪
中间的
Ten minutes
谢谢哇哈哈哈
谢谢老师
谢谢谢谢谢谢
谢谢真的要跟大家说再见了
♪ 谢谢晚安 ♪
♪ 谢谢 ♪
最后再次谢谢大家陪我到最后
谢谢拜拜
♪ 最后再次谢谢大大回 ♪
我到最后
啊马希林
我爱你
哇好棒啊好棒啊好棒
不要哭啦
再哭再哭
朋友我从来都没想过放电影好棒
不要穿了
哎呀好好欢迎我
好好的
很开心
加油了
不要哭
要哭了
呼哈哈呼哈哈
乌撒乌撒
♪ 放轻松快乐摇摆 ♪
♪ 张开双手迎接蓝蓝大海 ♪
♪ 乌撒乌撒 ♪
♪ 把烦恼统统抛开 ♪
♪ Say yeah ♪
乌沙乌沙
♪ 太阳要飞 ♪
♪ 管我们距离的走远 ♪
每天都是谁
♪ 想你的时候 ♪
♪ 它的甘甜甜甜 ♪
♪ what's up不stop ♪
♪ 累不累不累 ♪
再往前飞
♪ 冲锋准备安彻心扉 ♪
哦亲爱的你快换上新头像
好从此就开小说的你爱上它只是一个想你
♪ 谁没有答案 ♪
♪ 你还会有更多机会 ♪
♪ 很值得你去爱的人 ♪
♪ 在未来等着你 ♪
♪ 期待再见 ♪
♪ 自由难免是我家的浪漫 ♪
你们十个南北先给他
要不要不要多拍几张啊
留问他观众要不多拍几张好
我们再来再来
不要啊
你叫什么名字
我叫阿布拉啊
什么阿布拉
阿布的留言才刚刚回完
♪ 怎么心又开始发呆发呆 ♪
♪ 我的最新动态 ♪
♪ 是不是你也有点小期待 ♪
♪ H ♪
♪ 或许我该找个机会试探 ♪
♪ 看看你的心是否同样一想到你就会嘴角上扬 ♪
♪ 星期一穿拖鞋逛街 ♪
♪ 心情安慰 ♪
♪ 小事吵嘴无所谓无所谓 ♪
♪ 和你一起画面都很美 ♪
♪ 星期三笑着流眼泪 ♪
♪ 星期四 ♪
♪ 天冷相依偎 ♪
想和你周末对话不可改变
好好睡一觉
累不累
还好一毛了
一毛算一毛一毛吗
只有花海香香的舞时间一直去回忆
真美丽
♪ 天只想着你 ♪
♪ 你在我心底 ♪
♪ 不要说你爱我 ♪
♪ 你想我 ♪
♪ 如果你的心里没有这么做 ♪
♪ 只是勉强的敷衍我 ♪
♪ 我知道了会很难受 ♪
♪ 我要你默默走不回头 ♪
♪ 我会清楚明白你要的是什么 ♪
♪ 无需勉强的安慰 ♪
♪ 我说奇怪的理由 ♪
♪ 到现在还是深深地深深地爱着你 ♪
♪ 是爱情的友情的都可以 ♪
♪ 那是我心中的幸福 ♪
我知道它的苦苦的
到现在还是深深的深深的爱着你
♪ 是爱情的友情的都可以 ♪
♪ 那是我心中的幸福 ♪
♪ 我知道它苦苦的 ♪
亲妈发了
这是奶奶
嗯哇人越来越多了哈
大家好
今天看完
明天应该不会不来了
今天那个呃不要拍了
拜托了
因为没有化妆
明天比较美
明天再拍好不好
明天微要向未知远方
♪ 幸福路也许漫长 ♪
♪ 你是幸福 ♪
月光
♪ A la da da da ♪
我要去打针了啦
好可怕哦
打屁股打手
我要帮他们做着妈妈
好啊好快啊
你哪一台啊
你哪一台都很厉害
谢谢说你爱我
♪ 你想我 ♪
♪ 如果你的心里没有这么做 ♪
♪ 只是勉强的敷衍我 ♪
♪ 我知道了会很难受 ♪
♪ 我要你默默走不回头 ♪
♪ 我会清楚明白你要的是什么 ♪
♪ 无需勉强的安慰 ♪
♪ 我说奇怪的理由 ♪
♪ 到现在还是深深地深深地爱着你 ♪
♪ 是爱情的 ♪
♪ 友情的都可以 ♪
♪ 那是我心中的幸福 ♪
♪ 我知道它苦苦地留 ♪
才刚刚回暖
你的心
♪ 又开始发呆 ♪
好好听什么现场很好听
诶你好你好听
你带耳过来哦
不错哦
弯弯月光下
我的亲戚
有我马子全都买了
那边那边那边天津那边好啦
听完这首歌
他应该回去睡觉了啦
好不好
明天要记得再来哦
明天会来吗
喂喂喂
会不会会拍起来了
拍起来了又来了
♪ 不用你找你 ♪
夏天遇到从来不知道想你想
Oh ho baby
情话多说一点
想我就多看你一眼点
表现多一点点
♪ 让我能真的看到是我心中的幸福 ♪
♪ 我知道我 ♪
♪ 如果你 ♪
♪ 你今天不累吗 ♪
我好累了
然后回家睡觉啦
♪ 到现在还是深深地深深地爱着你 ♪
是爱情的
♪ 有幸福都可以 ♪
就这样好啦
现在都不走吼
等下跟我玩个游戏
跟我唱
我会好好听
你们要先唱
我会好好听啊
都给面子的
好不好
好
♪ 我会好好的 ♪
我会好好地
♪ 我还想想见 ♪
世界一直全世界一直美
♪ 真美丽 ♪
一直带走
♪ 我是想着你 ♪
♪ 一直想着你 ♪
你在我心里一起唱
♪ 变成了你的 ♪
♪ 那时我还是深深地深深地爱着你 ♪
是爱情的
♪ 友情的都可以 ♪
♪ 那是我心中的幸 ♪
♪ 我知道不孤独地留 ♪
谢谢
他没有唱的诶
可能是就是很不够意思
我想去台南这么有人情味
没有唱
一直支持我啊
无能无死杀
无能
乌撒乌撒放轻松快乐摇摆
♪ 张开双手迎接蓝蓝大海 ♪
♪ 乌SAWA ♪
♪ 把烦恼统统抛开 ♪
♪ Say yeah ♪
♪ say耶 ♪
乌撒乌撒
就这么温
我忘记我才不会问我有些难忘
我忘记的心情
♪ 雨哒哒哒 ♪
♪ 欢乐上快乐舞步 ♪
Ba ba ba
谢谢大家晚安啦
明天记得要来哦
晚上07:30
拜拜结束了吗
拜拜
太阳万岁
管我们距离有多远
♪ 你的心事想你的时候就在那天身边 ♪
太阳万岁月走在红红的身边
早上11点了
为什么要那么早来
因为想排前面
演唱会加油
王心凌
♪ 521 ♪
心怡不是受伤吗
希望他X队啊就早日康复
复这样
然后我们都很喜欢辛迪
希望你多多爱TINA
都一定会支持你的
♪ 虽然人不多 ♪
右边的朋友
重庆的毒牛哇哇重庆的毒牛快
手动们数到312376373667
对他为什么这么早
不会中暑吗
我们原本打算主机就要来了
狂踩
然后照顾自己的身体
多吃营养的东西
♪ 让我们去永远 ♪
都是新疆的党
我看他今日的是谁
等到了啊啊
天哪为什么那么早来啊
为什么看王心凌啊
谁做的呃
大家一起做
大家一起住就住多久了
不做
那做那么多要干嘛了解发发给大家
让大家跟大家一起分享啊
还有呢翻出来看一下最喜欢哪一句话
心里我们永远爱着你
支持你
♪ 在你背后 ♪
♪ 当时真的 ♪
啊就是现场南台湾的朋友们
我知道你们最热情的
只要你们自己不会昏倒
希望你们捐献出你们热情的掌声
OK吗
尤其是这个三商巧合的团体
三张巧合的心灵是这个到你是啊
你们是哪里过来的
台北台北真的假的
真的第一场
所以number one
所以当然要来看啦
除了加油还是加油
我会为你尖叫
不要紧张
星期一穿拖鞋逛街
心情和胃消失常的滋味无所谓
和你一起玩过很甜美
星期三笑
整整天黑
星期四天
♪ 不想让天机会 ♪
你的脸颊
♪ 在第一时间陪你跨微微笑 ♪
♪ 一深深的睡着 ♪
♪ 当时正赶走12天雨 ♪
♪ 大爱再也停不了 ♪
梦里的风真的舒服
Oh baby
情话多说一点
想我就多看一眼
表现多一点点
让我能真的看见
Oh bye
少说一点
想陪你不只一天多一点
让我心甘情愿爱你
睫毛弯弯眼睛眨啊眨
话说到嘴边怎么会转弯
你的微笑像月弯一弯
气氛好浪漫
需要你陪伴
睫毛弯弯眼睛眨阿眨
心动的世界变得好好玩
来晚的风吹吹什么吹
一见钟情的人
睫毛弯弯眼睛眨呀眨
话说到嘴边怎么会转弯
你的眼笑呵呵呵好
执行王心凌的王心冰
我会好好地花海
想象的时间已逝去
一直回忆真美丽
到现在还是深深的深深的爱着你
我会好好的
我会想象的时间已逝去
每一次你到现在还是深深的深深的爱着你
♪ 到现在还是深深地深深地爱着你 ♪
♪ 是爱情的 ♪
♪ 友情的都可以 ♪
那是我心中的幸福
我知道它苦不注定
到现在还是美
♪ 呜呜呼呜呼呜呼 ♪
♪ 小透明 ♪
♪ 星期一穿拖鞋逛街 ♪
♪ 心情安慰 ♪
♪ 小事吵嘴无所谓无所谓 ♪
和你一
我们永远支持你
希望心凌可以加油
祝新年演唱会可以成功
♪ 齐宁加油 ♪
爱你哟
新宁加油
继续加油
新宇加油
新年加油
西宁加油
希林加油
新宁加油
♪ 新新宇加油 ♪
希林加油
吉林加油
西宁加油
希林加油
吉林加油
♪ 吉林加油 ♪
希林加油加油
王俊林加油
新宁加油
吉林加油
力加油
还是那句话
我们会一直支持你
乌撒乌撒
♪ 放轻松快乐摇摆 ♪
♪ 张开双手迎接蓝蓝大海 ♪
♪ 乌SAWA ♪
♪ 把烦恼统统抛开 ♪
♪ Say yeah ♪
♪ 乌撒乌撒 ♪
♪ 乌云飘来 ♪
♪ 挥手拜拜 ♪
♪ 晴空万里 ♪
♪ 太阳可爱 ♪
♪ 风吹过来 ♪
♪ 速度有一点快 ♪
♪ 想爱就跟上节拍 ♪
♪ 眼泪放假 ♪
♪ 背上窗台 ♪
♪ 爱靠过来 ♪
大声say hi
歌词没有答案就怪我没而right
♪ 想爱就把心打开 ♪
♪ 不累不累 ♪
♪ 再往前飞 ♪
♪ 准备准备爱在心扉 ♪
菩萨放轻松吧
♪ 摇摆张开双手迎接蓝蓝大海路 ♪
撒乌撒啊
是我们记者大哥大姐们
他们都经生已深意了
因为就是要发稿嘛
嘿嘿you know
♪ 你太快 ♪
♪ 眼泪放假 ♪
♪ 背上转台 ♪
爱看到我的心海
我没看就没有坏人坏
♪ 想爱就把心打开 ♪
不累不累
再往前飞
所以充满装备
满大心跳
♪ 撒们轻松快乐摇摆 ♪
♪ 张开双手迎接蓝蓝大海 ♪
♪ 喔A哦撒把烦恼统统抛开 ♪
♪ Say yeah ♪
Yeah
说台南的人呢都会在家里先乖乖吃饭
然后再准时到
然后刚才在上去就是先拍照的时候啊
就觉得怎么到这还不来啊
然后连就是记者朋友啊
都会说哎呀他单是这样子的啦
就是大家已经是07:30以后
来的最多的时候是八点
我想说八点的开场都结束了
你们赶快来
拜托对啊
谈恋的朋友
你们给点面子嘛
人家北部都很捧场啊
这是特地来这边
刚刚拍照的时候
害我觉得很难过
没有啦
哈哈不行
再拜托大家了
吉利W加油
希林大楼外加油
哇哇哇
我们好像那个哈哈哈哈
倒数十页啊
加油加油一
5353放轻松快乐摇摆
♪ 展开笑手 ♪
茫茫大海不散不散
♪ 让烦恼通通抛开 ♪
3年耶
乌撒乌撒
♪ 太阳万岁 ♪
♪ 越过彩虹到你身边 ♪
太阳万岁
我当年距离要多远
有心事向你磕拍头
拍拍头
太阳万岁
管我们距离有多远
每天都新鲜
想你的时候
还在感爱
♪ 陪着我们寻找一种美好 ♪
有你给我暖暖拥抱
♪ 对我很重要 ♪
♪ 还陪着我们寻找这一刻 ♪
♪ 刚好到时间 ♪
♪ 反正12点雨到爱再也停不了 ♪
刚到台子都要下
我有坏对
Thank you
怎样可以告诉我有没有观众
你们到底开始心睫毛弯弯
♪ 眼睛眨啊眨 ♪
♪ 话说到嘴边怎么会转弯 ♪
♪ 你的微笑像月弯一弯 ♪
♪ 气氛好浪漫 ♪
♪ 需要你陪伴 ♪
♪ 睫毛弯 ♪
现在心情怎样
感觉有点紧张
非常紧张
因为怕怕出车
他们会累
唱完以后
被所有其他歌迷也有可能也有可能有可能
怎样有可能被干掉
我可能会回回不了家了
呵呵人家会有一个特别的人哦
轻轻一穿拖鞋逛街
心情安慰消失
张嘴无所谓无所谓
和你一起跨年都很美好
哇那我真想问你的
心情一穿拖鞋逛街
♪ 心情可味消失 ♪
♪ 酒醉无所谓 ♪
所谓和你一起跨年的
来来来各位你们superman3分钟3分钟
♪ 你把爱放进我的心里 ♪
♪ 关上耳朵 ♪
♪ 我用心在听 ♪
♪ 你用爱为我打造贴身耳机 ♪
♪ 点一首歌给honey隔空传递加心糖果BING ♪
♪ 更新彼此最新的秘密 ♪
♪ 爱要随身听 ♪
♪ 随时感应 ♪
♪ 如果有一天我回到从前 ♪
♪ 呜回到最原始的我 ♪
你是否会觉得我不错
♪ 如果有一天我离你遥远 ♪
♪ 不能再和你上演 ♪
♪ 你是否会发觉我已经说再见 ♪
♪ 快唱完一起唱好不好 ♪
♪ 当你的眼睛眯着笑 ♪
♪ 当你喝可乐 ♪
♪ 当你吵 ♪
♪ 我想对你好 ♪
♪ 你从来不知道想你想你也能成为嗜好 ♪
♪ 当你说今天的烦恼 ♪
♪ 当你说夜深你睡不着 ♪
♪ 我想对你说 ♪
♪ 却害怕 ♪
♪ 都说错 ♪
♪ 好喜欢你 ♪
知不知道
小心小心小心小心
♪ 失败无所谓 ♪
♪ 你在左右 ♪
♪ 月光多美 ♪
♪ 天徘徊在晚上 ♪
♪ 我轻轻在歌唱 ♪
♪ 从今以后不会再被一些 ♪
谢谢谢谢王心凌
总分鼓励
现场所有的好朋友还想不想听
一张一翔一起来准备123到
87565432
♪ 我还想想你拒绝你不是无情歌 ♪
♪ 谢谢你们 ♪
♪ 不要说你爱 ♪
♪ 我想过 ♪
♪ 如果你的心里没有这么做 ♪
只是勉强的敷衍我
我知道了会很难过
♪ 给你远方的祝福 ♪
♪ 我知道它苦苦地 ♪
谢谢江湖永远最美人
谢谢呵呵
我来谢谢
再次谢谢大家陪我到最后
谢谢
啊马希林
我爱你
哇好棒啊好棒啊好棒
不要哭啦
再哭再哭
哈哈哎呦
我从来都没想过放电影
好棒啊
不要拍了
哎呀
好好欢迎我
好好的
很开心
加油
不要哭不要哭哈哈太阳万岁
♪ 管我们距离有多远 ♪
每天风雨都新鲜
想你
但前面比较没唱好
不会啦
我继续讲
我听到最最最起的掌声来
欢迎来去玩剧
超人气的黄是领导的注意
♪ 我闭上眼听风说话 ♪
她说被爱的人那么精彩
尝试一下
来到舞台上
亲和力的甜蜜教主还会跟人家打屁
大傻大嘟嘟嘟哒哒哒哒哒哒嘟噜嘟噜噜哒哒哒
♪ 我们的爱像太阳一样 ♪
喔喔哦太阳万岁
♪ 管我们距离有多远 ♪
♪ 每天都新鲜 ♪
♪ 想你的时候悄悄看点点 ♪
♪ 太阳万岁 ♪
♪ 越过彩虹到你身边多美 ♪
♪ 梦想想实现就会实现 ♪
♪ 我闭上眼听风说话 ♪
♪ 他说被爱的人 ♪
♪ 你不用怕 ♪
♪ 我睁开眼睛看着微笑的阳光 ♪
♪ 你给的温暖保护爱不会照亮 ♪
♪ 永远围绕在我身旁喔 ♪
♪ 太阳万岁 ♪
♪ 管我们距离有多远 ♪
♪ 每天都新鲜 ♪
♪ 想你的时候 ♪
♪ 抬头看天边 ♪
♪ 太阳万岁 ♪
♪ 越过彩虹到你身边 ♪
HEHE梦想想实现就会实现
亲爱的各位
我亲爱的同事们
我的工作伙伴
我要说很sorry的事
其实我都有准备
但是我今天因为在台上那个哭了之后就忘记了
我还要谢谢这次的造型师琼英姐
谢谢你给我这么美丽的服装
还有美丽的奇毛安安脸上的爱心呢
要谢谢妙妙姐哦
来谢谢小迪
还有我美丽的头发呢
是嘉妮大师
哎
我妈妈当年的助理
然后还要谢谢所有的媒体朋友
谢谢你们
我今天很紧张
但是我在台下就是下台的时候
看到你们又为我鼓掌啊
还我不由的又很想哭了起来
然后他们就叫说不哭不哭
谁去换衣服
呵呵真的谢谢你们
谢谢谢谢大家
谢谢干杯
♪ 星期一穿妥协逛街 ♪
心情安慰
♪ 消失憔悴无所谓无所谓 ♪
♪ 和你一起画面都很美 ♪
♪ 星期三笑着流眼泪 ♪
♪ 星期四天冷相依偎 ♪
♪ 想和你周末约会 ♪
♪ 哦哦哦哦耶啦啦啦 ♪
♪ 和一起画面的美很美 ♪
♪ 等到啦哈 ♪
♪ 想和你周末约光 ♪
♪ 窗外在花香 ♪
♪ 我轻轻在歌唱 ♪
♪ 从今以后不会再被一首 ♪
谢谢谢谢王心凌
总分鼓励
现场所有的好朋友还想不想听
张艺翔一起来准备123到
87565432
♪ 我还想想你 ♪
♪ 世界一直是我心心 ♪
♪ 谢谢你们 ♪
♪ 不要说你爱我 ♪
如果你的心里没有这么做
只是勉强的敷衍我
我知道了会很难过
♪ 给你远方的祝福 ♪
♪ 我知道它苦苦地 ♪
谢谢江湖永远最美林
谢谢呵呵
♪ 天天看这些简单 ♪
张飞活到最后
啊马西林
我们你
哦好好好好完美大大好棒
不要哭啦
再哭再哭
哈哈哎呦
我从来都没想过放电影
好棒啊
不要拍了
哎呀
好好欢迎我
好好的
很开心
加油
不要哭不要哭哈哈太阳万岁
♪ 管我们距离有多远 ♪
每天美美都新鲜
想你
但前面比较没唱好
不会啦
你继续讲
我上听到最最最起的掌声
来欢迎蓝区玩具超人气的黄是领导的努力
♪ 我闭上眼听风说话 ♪
他说被爱的人
那么才尝试一下
来到舞台上
亲和力的甜蜜
教主还会跟人家打屁
大傻大嘟嘟嘟哒哒哒哒哒哒嘟噜嘟噜哒哒哒
♪ 我们的爱像太阳一样 ♪
喔喔哦太阳万岁
♪ 管我们距离有多远 ♪
♪ 每天都新鲜 ♪
♪ 想你的时候悄悄看点点 ♪
♪ 太阳万岁 ♪
♪ 越过彩虹到你身边 ♪
♪ 愿做美梦 ♪
♪ 想想实现就会实现 ♪
♪ 我闭上眼 ♪
你听风说话
♪ 他说被爱的人 ♪
♪ 你不用怕 ♪
♪ 我睁开眼睛看着微笑的阳光 ♪
♪ 你给的温暖保护爱不会照亮 ♪
♪ 永远围绕在我身旁喔 ♪
♪ 太阳万岁 ♪
管我们距离有多远
♪ 每天都新鲜 ♪
♪ 想你的时候 ♪
♪ 抬头看天边 ♪
♪ 太阳万岁 ♪
♪ 越过彩虹到你身边 ♪
多美
梦想尝实现就会实现
亲爱的各位
我亲爱的同事们
我的工作伙伴
我要说很sorry的事
其实我都有准备
但是我今天因为在台上那个哭了之后就忘记了
我还要谢谢这次的造型师琼英姐
谢谢你给我这么美丽的服装
♪ 谢谢小雅 ♪
还有美丽琪和们三点上的爱心呢
要谢谢妙妙姐啊
谢谢小吉
还有我美丽的头发呢
是佳尼大师
哎呦
妈妈要当你的助理
然后还要谢谢所有的媒体朋友
谢谢你们
我今天很紧张
但是我在台下就是下台的时候
看到你们又为我鼓掌
然后我不由的又很想哭了起来
然后他们就叫说不哭不哭
谁去换衣服
真的谢谢你们
谢谢谢谢大家
谢谢干杯耶
♪ 哇星期一穿拖鞋逛街 ♪
心情安慰
♪ 消失憔悴 ♪
♪ 无所谓无所谓 ♪
♪ 和你一起画面都很美 ♪
♪ 星期三笑着流眼泪 ♪
♪ 星期四天冷相依偎 ♪
♪ 想和你周末约会 ♪
♪ 哦哦哦哦哦耶来啦 ♪
♪ 在一起画面都很美很美 ♪
♪ 想和你周末月光 ♪